ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di guglielmo tell informate
all'interno del quale tramite instagram
vi chiedo che cosa posso fare
all'interno di un video stato subito a
leggere alcuni commenti e mi sono
arrivati abbiamo un po ha presentato le
psicosi ma chi sono io per giudicare di
un momento difficile per tutti quanti la
solitudine può portare a fare cose alle
quali poi in un secondo momento possiamo
sentirci ma carenza il cielo voi
rimarrete anonimi e soprattutto non
siete voi quelli che stanno facendo il
video le stanno mettendo in pratica
allora partiamo semplici per i soldi il
cubo di rubik
lo scrive celeste nessuno qui
confezionato ok
cerchiamo di incasinare partiamo aprì un
libro a caso inizia a rispondere alle
battute del personaggio noi camera un
signore degli anelli e quale sarebbe la
soluzione di questo rompicapo disse
teuten basta mandare tutto il riverso il
video e quindi sembra che fa il cubo di
rubik in realtà non lo fai isengard ma
anche a casa tua in realtà non vi sono
uomini sufficienti nel mark per assalire
la fortezza di saruman marche qui con me
già marca non so cosa abbia fatto no
disse teodem no disse con tutti i nodi
con non ho bisogno di mappe cioè proprio
senza waze senza google earth così
aquile arrivano le aquile arrivano le
aquile io vedo piccioni quanti pagano in
testa e belli stronzi che fanno a eccolo
infine disse gandalf faccio tardi spesso
è qui che scorreva il fiume non ero fare
pipì sirhan non arrivo del cancello
solevano chiamarlo io lo chiamo
ricreate uomini e donne con piedi con
patate la linea deve essere presente
bros non vale ok datemi una patata
coppie dico e patate che il richieste
fare di uomini e donne con le patate ora
preferisco direttamente fare uomini e
donne perché di notte io penso che lei
sia vestita da angelo ma è una donna
molto cattivo perché riesce a tirar
fuori delle cose che si capisce che non
si vede no ragazzi ma non era uomini e
donne era uomini con piedi con patate
come ha detto uomini e donne che nel suo
letto uomini ho letto uomini e donne un
goccio di uomini con
che cos'è uomini con piedi prova
vestirti come uno dei personaggi drome
guglielmo rese in cir e qualsiasi cosa
imitando camion recensire questo qui è
un cubo di rubik cm e il culo voglia di
regia cazzo dura con umiltà e accingo
cioè e kio passetto cazzo e poi voglio
dire a monza perugia da romy cioè questi
qui gli fanno grossi così anche sticazzi
cioè voglio dire cazzo fotte sega
l'altro in culo piscio e proprio cazzo
cazzo cazzo chicca immune cazzo romy
aimone non izzi travel agency e il gioco
di tavolo gioco da tavolo giochi da
tavolo nel frattempo faccio come dire un
pick up e rossetti umile umile borghese
e militati cassi dai stop questa è
l'ultima storia a me foto e sega cioè di
imparare cioè cazzo fotte sega [ __ ]
aimone aromi travel agency umile
borghese passetto passetto hashtag
regalo così almeno mi ha fatto i
problemi che non per i [ __ ] da
ultimo storia ti voglio bene cammina e
non credo di avvertire su giustizia se
molto più pazza di così manda un self
con una matita nel naso di un follower a
caso fede si stanno le applico un filtro
chiamato nonno e parlarle usando
citazioni della disney
lasciamo in pace e mia nonna
è una mamma eccolo area e poi ma mirto
come stacul do pacifico
no perché fino all'altro ieri mangiava
delle dozzine di uova noi sta bene
adesso con i nuovi croccantini sono a
base proteica anche quattro dozzine kakà
più dura va bene siamo un po tutti
quanti collegati nel grande cerchio
della vita quindi che abbiamo tutti la
carta è molto più tranquilla lo sai ora
che non c'è più lui lei è una di quelle
che se continua a guardare indietro alla
fine non vedremo ciò che davanti quindi
voglio dire la stessa cosa lei con la
sua magia da berna ma vale la pena a
sciogliersi per qualcuno alla fine fa
solamente una tipica attenzione erano
rifaccia al più della goccia di vino
programma domani può aspettare comunque
quindi c'è il gatto che piscia per
quattro volte la cuccia di cui lei non
riesco proprio a capire come un mondo
che crea cosa è tanto meravigliose poi
possa essere cattivo capire un club lo
so però due mesi ma guardiano appositi
tir o qualunque cosa accada sarò al tuo
fianco per sempre coli e sta
tranquillissimo fuori sento un sacco di
odori perché evidentemente un prezioso
anche di calore delle femmine
ma questo qui è un momento particolare
cioè il fiora che sbocciano nelle
avversità poi è più prezioso di tool e
se ci pensi quindi questo quel momento
parlando come se fossi in collegamento
orario no ma anche sono un momento
innamorato e quindi le persone fanno
sempre cose pazze quando sono innamorate
video che dovevo parlarti con citazioni
della disney a tecniche banca team che
ho scavato davanti alla videocamera ma
ti svelo un segreto tutti i migliori
sono matti senti ma mi ti bacio dai non
smettere mai di sognare solo chi sogna
popolare un basso ci descrivi tutto il
team come se tu fossi alberto angela e
loro delle opere d'arte e reperti
archeologici arrivando all'interno della
società
la prima cosa che si può trovare è uno
stambecco uno stambecco alto quasi due
metri
il suo nome è già un pazzo specie su
urlanti sede un essere che per
accoppiarsi il più delle volte dice che
qualcosa non gli piace vicino a lui il
gran macigno un monte secolare grosso è
ingombrante con la velocità di un
bradipo muovendosi più in avanti e
riuscendo a inserire nelle orecchie dei
tappi per evitare lo stordimento fonico
si arriva all interno della caverna p la
linea è un tipo di macaco urlanti che
come richiamo d'amore utilizzate i
decibel che possono essere interpretati
solamente da delfini pipistrelli e
rugbisti particolarmente focosi alla
fine nell'altro della solitudine
troviamo graziano abitante degli abissi
all'apparenza un grande piano quasi un
granchio che cerca di nutrirsi di
plancton o piccoli molluschi ma che è
destinato tendenzialmente alla non
riproduzione eterna un dissing repato
contro che ti sta sul cazzo ultimamente
i tre puntini alla fine di una frase li
metti solo se vuoi fare muro se io li
vedo metto un punto e ti mando poi a
[ __ ] e non pensare che io stia dietro
a quello che ogni giorno fa e se tu un
problema con me hai non scriverlo su
facebook ma scrivilo su workshop vanno a
fare freestyler ragazzi qualcuno mi può
scrivere un freestyle qua sotto suona il
pianoforte bendato che cielo aperto
[Applauso]
fare una faccia da me me e poi creare il
meme adeguato a quella faccia
[Musica]
prova a superare stupidi record mondiali
non ne posso fare troppi rackham qui
abbiamo un tizio che ha mangiato un
aeroplano contenuto di alcol nel sangue
più alto cioè era praticamente su alcol
e nucci in bocca 259 cannucce
contemporaneamente che soffre 250 che so
che la mia fame mi precede però ecco non
so se fino a questo livello
datemi allora queste qui a pacchetto
sono 24 camilluccia in carta eco
friendly più difficile per loro queste
cartoline a 259 ne abbiamo 11 pacchi 11
ma che non ce la farò mai
ma chi era questo qua ok segnalati
piaceva di più ma perché mi è preso 24
del 4 ce la faccio
tra un ottimo stretching giorni
sopravvalutate siamo arrivati alla fine
di questo video spero che vi abbia
divertito a farmi sapere qua sotto quali
sono altre cose dovesse vedere nei
prossimi guglielmo tell
fino ad allora vi mando un bacio
scegliamo domenica con una puntata di
cucina buttata tra tante sinistra
dicendo gianmarco un sacco di persone
riguardano i nostri video non sono
iscritti al canale a serie delle merde
molto di costa cliccare con il mouse la
campanella cioè quando qualcuno vi
chiede di accoppiarsi con lui o con lei
mi pesa di meno a coppiardi che fare un
clic
non so come mi sia uscita questa cosa ma
richiede molta più fatica a fare un
booklet che clikkare o iscriviti che
richiede molta più fatica a farsene in
fila
quindi voglio dire rischi di sporca
inning
avevi per attendere l'amore non riesce a
fare clicca su iscriviti
lo prendo come un affronto personale